they say the best songs of names any
ideas
earth keeper
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video I want to continue
doing my character breakdowns for the
final season so today I will be covering
Brienne of Tarth even though there are
only six episodes left they still need
to wrap up a lot of different storylines
before the show ends but today I only
want to talk about Berean of Tarth and
the direction I think her story is
heading in there are two different ways
I can see her story ending so I want to
go over both of those scenarios but
first I want to pick up right where we
left off at the end of season 7 the last
time we saw Brienne was in the season 7
finale during the meeting at the dragon
pit she was there during the big
presentation when Cersei was shown the
evidence of the real threat that was
beyond the wall Brienne might not have
played much of a role during that part
but she did say something interesting to
Jaime before he left and I think it did
plant the seed in Jamie's head about
what's really important at the time
Jaime didn't seem to care but later he
did realize the position they were in
and I think he made the right choice
when he finally decided to leave Cersei
in King's Landing Brienne is arguably
the most positive influence Jaime has
ever had in his life and she is
responsible for Jaime's metamorphosis he
went from a character that most people
despised but thanks to Brienne he has
grown into a character that a lot of
people have grown to love including me
Jaime will eventually arrive in
Winterfell to help them beat the army of
the dead but Jaime isn't just going to
be welcomed into the North with open
arms this is where Brienne will come
into play when Jaime shows up Brienne
will be the one to stand up and vouch
for Jaime Lannister this should be
pretty interesting to see because people
are gonna be pissed when Jaime shows up
even if he is there to help they are
going to believe a word he says once
people find out Jamie pushed brain out
of the window I could see people asking
for his head to be taken off Brienne
will have to explain that Jaime was the
one who gave her that Valyrian steel
sword and the reason he gave it to her
was so that she could find and protect
sons of Stark
it's yours I can't accessory falls from
its dark sword you use it to defend Ned
Stark's daughter sworn oath we're trying
to stop goes to the mother during that
time Cersei won it's on his head but
Jaime was hoping Brienne could find her
first and keep her safe
Jaime felt like that was his last chance
at having any shred of Honor by
upholding his word to Catelyn Stark bran
could actually vouch for this - if bran
was able to see Littlefinger and Varys
having a conversation in the throne room
then he could see all of the things
Jaime said to Brienne it will also be up
to brand to whether he wants to have
Jaime killed or not since he was the one
Jaime did try to kill but I believe bran
will see this as his destiny and he will
allow Jaime to live for some reason I
don't see bran wanting Jaime dead but I
don't want to go too far down that road
in this video because I want to keep
this one about Brienne like I said
earlier when Jaime shows up Brienne will
be one of the few people to stand up and
vows for Jaime they will ultimately
allow Jaime to fight with them they're
not gonna like it but they will see that
maybe he can be useful in some way when
the great war begins it will be fun to
see all of these characters fighting
alongside one another I mentioned this
in my video about the Hound but it will
be nice to see Brienne and the Hound
fighting side-by-side at the end of
season 4 these two characters nearly
killed each other but now they will be
relying on each other for survival and I
think it would be interesting if we
would see Brienne save the Hound or the
Hound save Brienne neither one of them
would expect it but it would let them
know and the audience know that there is
no bad blood between them and maybe they
were both wrong about each other I do
expect Brienne to survive the war not
only is she one of the greatest fighters
remaining in Westeros but she also has a
Valyrian steel sword that she knows how
to wield very well her strength her size
her fighting ability and the sword that
she carries will keep her alive and I
think we will even see her kill a white
Walker it will be very interesting to
see some of the other characters go
toe-to-toe with some of the white
walkers we have already seen Jon kill
two of them but since Brienne and Arya
have Valyrian steel I would like to see
both of them fight why
Walker's to it will be fun watching
everyone kick some white Walker ass but
it won't be that easy
I do think Brianne will live but she
will also lose a few people that are
very close to her I know some people are
probably hoping that this ends was some
sort of love story with Brian and Jamie
but I do not see that happening nor do I
see Breanna and tormund getting together
at the end either
I think Brianne will outlive both of
them if history has taught us anything
it has taught us that intimate
relationships do not last in this story
almost every couple has been either
ripped apart or killed over the span of
this series during a recent interview
someone asked the showrunners about
torment and Brianne and they basically
said one of them will die
tormund was lucky to survive the mission
beyond the wall and he was nearly ripped
apart and pulled into the lake then he
was lucky again during the tackle on the
wall he has lived long enough to make it
to the last season but I don't see him
surviving the wars I do have to say I
would hate to see him go because he is
one of my favorite characters but I just
don't see him making it out of
everything and the same thing goes for
Jamie Lannister
I don't see him having a happy ending
either but I do see him having an
honorable death I know I've said this
before and I will say it again I believe
Jamie will die by protecting someone
else he will sacrifice himself for one
of the Starks or maybe even Brienne I do
think he will die in the arms of the
woman that he loves and that woman will
be Brienne and one thing that has
bothered Jamie for a very long time is
the deeds that he has done this is shown
more in the books than it is in the show
but Jamie is constantly thinking about
the white book so Jamie Lannister
someone forgot to write down all your
great deeds but still time is there for
a forty road night with one hand he is
always opening the book and looking
through it and thinking about how his
pages don't say much at all he doesn't
only want to be remembered as the person
who killed the king that he had sworn to
protect he doesn't want that to be his
only legacy and this is one of the
reasons why I think his story will end
with him doing one of the most honorable
things someone can do which is
sacrificing themselves to save someone
else when Jaime does do this I think
Brienne will be the one to make sure
Jaime is remembered for the good deeds
that he had done she will make sure the
truth is written somewhere Jaime had a
good reason to kill the Mad King and He
gave His life so that someone else could
live Jaime can't have his own
bittersweet ending he will die but what
he did will not be forgotten in Burien
will play a big role in that in my
opinion now when it comes to how Bryan's
story will end there are two different
ways I can see this going down like I
said earlier I think Brienne will live
but if she does what would she do after
the wars are over well she could be
relieved of her duties she swore an oath
to protect lady Catelyn starters and she
did that to the best of her ability
Sean's and Arya refused her at first but
they both made it safely home and
Podrick kind of mentioned this when
Sansa Arya and bran reunited
[Music]
Catelyn Stark would be proud you kept
your vow
I did next to nothing to harden yourself
my lady I'm not
[Music]
Thank You mojo Brianne did do what she
could and this will continue next season
but when the fighting is finally done
Songza may tell Bree and she doesn't
have to spend the rest of her life
watching over them
Brianne already put her life on the line
several times trying to rescue them or
even escort them home and Songza may
reward her and relieve her of her oath
so that Brianne can retire and enjoy the
rest of her life however she chooses if
Brianne has given this option I do think
she would give the Starks their Valyrian
steel back Bryan knows the sword she is
carrying came from a tart Starks or dice
knowing Brianne she would want them to
get that back and it would definitely
mean a lot to the Starks even if they
never had ice were forged and put back
together just knowing where the steel
came from would be enough personally I
would really love to see this and I
think most of you know this already I
would love if the Starks were able to
get both swords back because that steel
has been in their family for a very long
time
once the wars are over I could see this
happening but there is another option
things could end a bit differently
assuming that Sansa lives she would most
likely remain the lady of Winterfell and
possibly even the Queen in the north if
that did happen Bryan might want to form
a sort of Queen's Guard for Sansa in
Brienne could be the commander of that
Queen's Guard then Brienne could
continue to keep the sword Oathkeeper
she could continue to protect Ned
Stark's daughter with Ned Stark's
Valyrian steel I kind of go back and
forth with both of those endings
and I would be satisfied with either one
Brienne could be relieved of her duties
and allowed to leave and live out the
rest of her life wherever she wants or
she could choose to stay and become
Songz's Queen's Guard
either way Brienne will live but this
isn't necessarily a happy ending for
Bereans story because she will have lost
along the way Renly died lady Catelyn
died and Jaime may die but Brienne could
live knowing that she kept her oath by
doing everything that she could to see
that Lady Catlins daughters were kept
safe I talked about Maria and making
sure Jaime's pages were filled in the
white book but there is something else
Brienne can do for someone I think
Brienne could have Podrick knighted pod
has been a very loyal Squire to more
than one person in Berean has been
a lot of time training Podrick to become
just as good as a fighter that she is
they have shown us this over and over
again in Berea and even said herself
Podrick is a very competent swordsman
now I think he will prove himself on the
battlefield and he may even save Brienne
just like he saved Tyrion during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay
if that would happen I definitely think
Brienne would want to reward Podrick by
having him knighted but I already talked
about some of this in my Podrick video
when you have time you should check out
some of my other character breakdown
videos if you click on the video tab at
the top of the page then you can see all
the videos I have made let me know what
you think will happen to Brienne next do
you agree with some of the things that I
said or do you think her story will end
differently I am curious to see what
some of you have to say so put all your
thoughts and questions down below I want
to thank everyone for stopping by to
watch today's video I really appreciate
that and I also want to thank all of my
patreon supporters have a great day
everyone I will see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]